does anybody remember
did we talk about this yaya kung food
does anybody remember that game
i worked on a clone of it once
really for what platform
for like so clone is too strong a word
but a homage uh called um
was it called invincible tag of the
legend of han dao and it was a xbox live
arcade game i think it holds the
distinction being one of the first true
3d
uh video games
like in terms of the working with 3d tvs
i've never heard of it what was it
it was it was a i mean if you look up
images of it it's the game that troy's
talking about just with xbox 360 era
graphics basically it's exactly the same
game this is like i think 1982
i had my what what i considered to be
what uh what i called my safeway
classics which would be the grocery
store where i grew up was called safeway
and they would always rotate you know
out whatever new video game was coming
through and i remember the day that they
wheeled it was old my weight
i'm old use take two two's better
um
i can just do it for a third time can
you just do it a bit slower one more
time
i i hear the note i just i want to let
you know i disagree with it
george lucas please just please write it
right right speaker's written
[Laughter]
he so i remember the day that they
rolled in
the pac-man machine um and the centipede
machine and then miss pac-man you're
seeing the progressional levels so like
this this goes back to like 1981
and
um
one of those games was kung fu master
was one and i always always have like
maybe a quarter so i had to make every
life count and there was no worse
feeling than getting to almost the end
of a level
and that's it you died and i was like
that's that's all i have and so i would
sit there and i would
play and let the you know the loop that
they would be on to kind of show the the
splash screen or whatever i i would
pretend that that was me playing uh but
this is one of the games i could do and
i never yesterday was the first time in
35 years or whatever that actually got
past where i last left off when i was
standing at the arcade when i was like a
seven-year-old
how does that feel
amazing and then i got my ass kicked on
the next guy so it's it's like playing
mike tyson's punch out you're like you
can never beat mike tyson never i've
never i've never finished that game no
bald bull sure i might put that on my
list like so go for it my number one
life goal is to go to space it remains
that is what i want to do in life life
girl
very calm
yesterday was telling me that his
current
life path goal that he is on is to take
a photo with every stegosaurus that is
currently fully built in the entire
world and there are 50.
and he's like almost happened to be that
many
i know
so it means that he's going around the
world intentionally looking at museums
that have the stegosaurus the
stegosaurus to take photos with them and
i was like [ __ ] hell i want to figure
out more like
adventurous life goals like beating mike
tyson
i might add that to the listener just
like
you do i'm going to do i want to do a
speed run of contra um
in different places right so like you
could say that i i did it i beat it in
the louvre which
what's the most millennial [ __ ] thing
that you can do i was in the vatican i
did speedrunner contra
45 minutes
[ __ ]
yeah i'm just uh
i'm just a fan of the idea of creating
more subtle life goals in general that
are like fun things to try to accomplish
and i really do feel like beating mike
tyson is a good one to have is it
because it's specific or endemic to you
or is it because you feel that it's
truly attainable like i
do you have a tendency to set goals that
are
like man that's that's that's gonna be
really really hard for me to reach or
you're like no i i can do this like how
long term are your goals are they 30 60
90 or they're like
90 year old self um every year and my
goals are always
only ever things that i can actually
personally accomplish like you know
content creators will sometimes be like
get a hundred thousand subscribers i
make sure not to do that because i think
that'll drive you insane i do like
finish a book
do this amount of this thing reading or
writing start this either you know like
i just make sure that the goals that i
have are things that
i can
do and that do not depend on other
people yeah yeah
that's the distinction that makes yeah
because i feel like there are people who
like you know full-time twitch streamers
who are like gay this many subscribers i
just feel like you drive yourself crazy
so mike tyson appeals to me because
yes it's attainable i know the space one
is is not very attainable i don't know
that i'll be able to do that but one
hundred percent
a lifetime that's the thing it seems
like it's getting 100 is i just might be
super old
you're gonna like the price is gonna
come down you're gonna age at some point
those two marks will cross and that's
what right now it's like i have a graph
actually sure
[Laughter]
but then i threw up a graph once as a
joke and genuine for the exact because
that's my life goal as well so at some
point go to space proper space do you
think what do you mean not like outer or
or uh what's it called
no i'll
but you're talking like somewhere
between the 237 000 miles between us and
the moon are you talking to like [ __ ] it
i want to go to mars i want to look out
every window and it to be black
really yeah that's that might be that's
a whole other lifetime that's what i
want
i think my version of that is i wouldn't
mind
i need to sell out well let's start
running ads on the podcast
i've always thought that if i got a
life uh a terminal
disease contact i i yeah i'd want to
exactly john hurt i'd want to go the
same way and get blasted off one way and
just drift but they'd never send you for
that reason right like a desire to stay
alive is something that's quite
important in an astronaut
well yeah i mean this is
disqualified for that your desire to go
on a one-way mission would disqualify
you for being yes but point of order to
john hurt's you know narrativized
fiction
sure the ability for him to be able to
be so ridiculously wealthy that not only
was he able to launch himself into space
but he built two of those [ __ ] i need to
watch that movie again it's so good just
watched it recently and it's still so
good that's to me that's jody foster's
best
best performance
not the one that won the oscar for the
accused i mean well we're tax drivers
i'm also discounting nell that's a solid
you can't that was the one where i was
just swinging a miss tayden in the wind
nope what about no what about uh
what
agent um you don't know all blonde
actresses look the same to you
um no that was naomi watts
is it starlet why am i suddenly blanking
this is uh sacrilege that was baby watts
uh that was nicole kidman
what about agent starling what's agent
starling what [ __ ] songs
oh [ __ ] yeah i forgot her name
clarice
um not her best performance
hmm how subjective do you think that is
you know like totally yeah
i mean any opinion is subjective but
where do we pull that from is my better
question is
like what is this
choice for the right what is it about
that
foreign kidding it is i believed her
genuine passion
um i believe that
i wasn't seeing a character the only
time it was like i don't think you
really want to be here do you think it's
more helpful if you relate to the
character
do you think that that a piece of you is
needed for you to find it more
believable
saying
a piece of me like i have that passion
so therefore i empathetically maybe you
know yeah i could see that
i think you're also more qualified to
see the nuance of a performance than
non-actors right i've always like i
don't know i always have these
conversations with like i think you've
got more experience so you can you're
enjoying on a different level not
necessarily that your opinion matters
more but like you definitely will have a
more nuanced perspective on the average
kind of
i'm looking for different things sure
like i i watched um
i picked back up with west wing and i
was watching this one episode that was
just uh
essentially was just a one play or not
not even a one act play but it was just
a it was an isolated episode
and
something that a lot of people don't
think would understand but looking at it
from
a
structure standpoint a writing
standpoint a performance standpoint a
directorial standpoint
what they did in this seemingly
pedestrian episode was phenomenal
and it started and ended with um abby
and and judd in bed like one starting
their day and the other ending their day
and the last line of the episode it was
a real cool challenge for me as an actor
because i i literally paused it as i
often do watching these episodes and i
go
[ __ ]
and it just it it there's a light bulb
moment there's a paradigm shift for me
as an actor that goes that's trust
that's
being courageous that's doing something
and it was one line from martin sheen
off of uh um
what's her name not channing tatum uh
soccer channing
stalker channing tatum
who says um
are you getting up at six tomorrow and
he goes
no i gotta get a um
i've called him getting up early
and it that's the last line of the
episode and so as an actor as a director
i would go go and give us a button on
that that's the le that's the last line
of our episode
and what he chooses to do but that's not
how people talk that's not how a married
couple of 25 or 30 years
would say something so
offhanded and unimportant to them they
don't know it's the end of the episode
now i gotta get up early tomorrow and
credits i was like
ah it just lent itself so much
authenticity off of the seemingly wrong
choice
so stuff like that i pick up on
um
but i i i don't feel like i'm more
qualified to discern a good performance
versus a bad
because i think alana you're right
there's something that inherently i must
do i connect with
the character and that it speaks to
it's not it's not design it's not
directing it's not actor it's not
writing it's all of those things fitting
together and can i believe that i'm this
person
i love the fact that we've seen this
rise of female i've been talking a
little while i'm sorry
there's there's this rise of a female
protagonist right what do you think this
is some kind of podcast
but there's like
i remember playing horizon zero dawn
even before tomb raider and everything
else it didn't really click for me until
like horizon zero dawn
the last of us where i was like
[ __ ] hell man
if if you're not a dude
it's it's a it's a must be a
a higher barrier of entry to play a game
because you're like i have to believe
that i'm marcus phoenix as opposed to me
is like there's one degree removed from
that
and
i remember the same thing watching
wonder woman um which we can you know
pick apart that move we want to but what
i the best thing about wonder woman
was that
seeing all of the pictures of people
posting the just the massive outpouring
of female audiences that went to go see
it and mask together and we're like
finally we feel represented finally we
have someone we've been watching
let me tell you wonder woman i didn't
like that movie right the opening of
that movie with all these cool women
together fighting made me tear up it's
not even representation
it's
oh my god we've never looked that cool
before [ __ ] ever is this how white
dudes feel all the time and you go and
you watch that you're like i can
accomplish anything that was the best
part it was like just so
[ __ ] cool in a way that you like i
didn't even realize that i had never
seen before until seeing that and you
know i grew up playing video games i did
have joanna dark and i did have jade
from beyond good and evil and all these
female characters that i liked but it's
actually
not that
i never had trouble being like oh i have
to relate to this character i think that
that's more of like a tremendous
privilege that is offered to you not
something that feels like it's missing
for me if that makes sense like i'm like
oh cool i'll learn about this character
but it was okay with me if i never
saw myself in them because that was just
the way that it was and it never hurt me
so the idea of growing up and seeing
yourself in all of these protagonists is
just like like i said a massive
privilege i know that's such a buzz word
but it's just like a thing that is like
that must have been [ __ ] awesome but
it's not like i ever felt like i was
missing something because i had no
concept of what i was missing
interesting i was just like i like this
dude
i'm a fan but i did i i really did love
joanna doc and like you know i played a
lot of banjo-kazooie and there were
female characters in that that i really
loved so there were you know definitely
female characters that i really liked
but it yeah it's just a
i feel like the big thing especially
speaking as a white woman like whether
either the second in hand or the lead of
every other thing you know is still um
just not not thinking that i was cool is
what it is he's like you never get your
action hero cool guy
that i feel like men just like get to
see on every
every everything like again wonder woman
i was like [ __ ] hell this is the
coolest thing i've ever seen there was
really only two of those right there was
there was
samus and when she didn't even find out
until the end of two and samus didn't
didn't uh have a positive impact on me
because it was a plot twist not a
genuine
right
but i'm just saying like as far as like
i was like oh weird we didn't really
have
there there weren't a lot of options
and even fewer for like
if you again if you just weren't a white
dude like if any any variation of purple
a person of color
there wasn't that
you didn't have a lot of options
i don't know i don't know how i got
dovetailed off into that but
it was just it was something that i i
really appreciated um
and to your point mike i i think that i
don't think i'm over qualified than
anybody else i think anybody is capable
it's it's to austin's um
thing that i love that he quotes so much
is that anyone can cook
um
it's not a critic that is more
qualified it's just someone who
people listen to more that's all
qualifier i would think
technically that's correct but that
you
[Music]
having
done what you do for a living as long as
you have would
at least pick up on things that i
wouldn't notice
like
i feel like i'm gonna maybe derail the
whole episode by saying this but i
cannot stand
ted lasso season two i don't remember if
i said that i cannot stand it
interesting i would love to talk about
that
i had to stop watching awesome
like i've never seen a single
you haven't even seen this first season
it's such a happy birthday
yeah no i i need to watch it because so
many people i like love it um it's
definitely something i we watched like
the first half of the first episode and
both just bounced off it immediately i
think we were maybe in the wrong mood or
something that would be my guess so
we'll go back season one i i loved
season two i had this issue that i was
like not a lot of people are probably
gonna feel this way but i can just see
the words on the page i can see the
this conflict is needed or like we're
going to put this in here so we can get
this wholesome moment because we
recognize that the audience likes this
and it's i and i don't know if that's
the thing that as someone who is writing
furiously all day every day right now
if it's that i'm like oh i can see
exactly what you needed to get out of
what you wrote and you shout darkest
arrow at the screen as well right every
single time like that's it's always that
just a me thing no you definitely sit
and watch like hollywood movies and i'm
like oh we're breaking into the second
act now that's great yeah
yeah this is our darkest hour yeah i
think it's it is a problem it's true of
game design development as well like
once you've built some levels you're
like oh okay you run out of money at
this point
i literally replaying shadow complex at
the moment and about halfway through the
main character just puts a mask on and
keeps on for the rest of the game like
oh okay you can get all of the i see why
you did that yeah yeah yeah our polish
budget is what [ __ ] it all right
nobody speaks anymore
i
that's that's an interesting
i i definitely think that um
you could become hypersensitive to
certain things i i remember um do we
lose austin or is he frozen for no i i
well there's just so many places that i
that i
that i kind of want to go but he's
picking he's picking which tangent to
take us off
yeah he's looking at the multiverse
right now he's figuring out the thing
that most uh the thing that that most
sort of grabbed me is increasingly long
ago in your
diatribe uh troy
um because
um
the i remember
years ago at gdc richard lamarche gave a
s uh speech
about game design in general uh on the
back of uncharted three and he
he talked about how
you know the the buzzword it still is
but especially then the big buzz word in
game design is always immersion
and he
he pushed back against that and said
you know understood properly immersion
is like
the
the boundaries of reality melt away and
i'm so lost in the game i don't even
know
that i'm in the game anymore i'm just
it's just it has become synonymous with
my life like i'm just so immersed that i
don't i i i i'm just in it and he and he
said you know
um
if that were actually real and he shows
he shows the scene from
uncharted 3 of like hanging out the back
of the plane and he's like this would be
the worst experience of your life
he goes so i don't think
i don't think we're correctly labeling
what we're after he goes it's not
immersion it's attention how do we
simply captivate the player immersion is
is a kind of a way to think of it but
the reality is just simply
um
is your attention held and i always
thought that was a really interesting
differentiation and so
with that as a kind of frame as i listen
to you describe
you know resonating or not with certain
performances and going like alana says
well what makes this
what makes contact better than
uh silence of the lambs for jody foster
and if you say
something along the lines of your
ability to kind of can like empathize or
feel a
an honesty um in it
um it sounds to me like a kind of
analogy to immersion versus attention
because it takes us back to the
it takes us like in other words
immersion equals i fail to see
a character i see a real person
uh she transformed into a a whole other
human being and that's sort of the
zenith of acting but i i always go back
to the classic
thing that we've talked about a million
times of the
of the lawrence olivier versus um
uh dustin hoffman dustin hoffman um
where it's like acting
is performance acting in the lawrence
olivier model it's not about believing i
am this other person it's i am simply
performing to hold your attention
and the ala the differentiation that
richard drew and i think that that's
interesting like
the idea that i'm not olivier is not
convincing you
this whole other human being has been
created before your very eyes it's
simply
do i command your attention with my
performance and
isn't that
i mean like for example
isn't that kind of the al pacino thing
like he's basically always that right
but he's
but he but he you can't look away um
so i don't know to me i i found myself
instinctively saying i'm not sure that
because you yes you have the gary
oldman's
the rare breed who seemingly can truly
vanish inside a character and just cease
to be gary oldman
um often as much a credit to
costume and
make up for all the other departments as
well but mortal beloved and everything
else you like but he really can yeah
like he yeah if you if you just do a
quick slide show through his
performances you're like okay that guy
is really on another level
period but that but that's where i was
saying you know i don't know to me
it's an interesting
um
it's an interesting test of what really
is good acting if
i'm not sure that i accept the premise
that they have to kind of vanish
um
which then makes it difficult to say
what's better and what's not if it's
man what an interesting qualifier
i feel like mike you have something that
you wanted to don't get try don't don't
you're trying to weasel out of uh
answering definitively
all these existential questions nothing
of value to add beyond
what's the one thing that's something
that i think backs up what you're saying
austin is how many award-winning
performances
are
like shout outs attention-seeking yeah
right like they're shouty they're
uh working with prosthetics they're
they're like they're big showy offie
roles right so funny wow that character
that actor played did a really good job
of playing like a standard person you
know what i mean or
a the the your your mate down the pub
it's always so much bigger historical
figures that kind of thing like just
very big shows big speeches yeah it's so
true i i remember an actor friend of
mine
um
saying something true whatever
different one before i had to cast him
out you have more than one
how many
no it was more like an rpg party where i
realized i had to exchange the other guy
so i um i got rid of him in favor you
should feel very honored troy but thank
you no he um he i remember him saying
that you know he was like i'll never win
an award because i'm trying to focus on
such subtle details as an actor
that
awards tend to notice the showy
attention-seeking stuff like you just
said mike although funny enough the
other day i
one time like once ever i i liked some
random
post on instagram that now they
algorithmically feed me all these
like actor memes or something because i
saw this one the other day that was
actually really cool of it was a bunch
of actors
and it was like side by side
them doing one of those big shouty
things that is famous and then them
doing this really quiet restrained thing
that's not famous the same actor kind of
just juxtaposing the two
and um
some of them were really you know you
it's like yeah no one's ever gonna
give an oscar to the one on the right
side of the frame but it's powerful dude
it can be so powerful the thing that
like i think more consistently breaks me
than anything
and i troy you did this in the last of
his part too and i think i texted you
about it is and i think it's because i
watch so much forensic files
that i relate to this that the way that
men often cry in real life you're
watching someone in their face try not
to cry it's not that they sob and a lot
of actors just go straight for the sob
but when you watch a man it's especially
like when it's a dad that it gets me
try not to cry it's very much a man just
trying to hold it in and you're watching
his face like sort of move because he's
trying not to tear up and anytime i see
that in a performance it breaks my heart
because you know all of the layers that
go into that but that's like exactly
like you're saying not the award-winning
performance that's a little subtle tiny
little thing that somebody's picked up
on and is trying to enact when it's
easier to solve when the sobbing is the
dramatic performance that we're like oh
yes very uh that's captivating
man talk about going for it
and
in part one
the sarah scene that's
exactly i was like watch this [ __ ]
i'm gonna give you some award-winning
[ __ ]
i had my eye
on the whole [ __ ] gallery jeff keeley
would create an award
for me
there would be no other awards needed
in fairness like he does love to make
awards so you know
most here joker we're in ford
go see there's no surprise here guys
but first
an exclusive trailer um i love you jeff
but man learning understanding
learning and understanding because those
are two separate events um and i think i
i know that because i stepped through
that there was the learning it the the
assessment and the in the acquisition of
new knowledge
and then the understanding of it
of
i'm i'm doing something for my own
benefit and
it really just came i i've been in that
situation where
a perfect example of this is is a friend
of mine ryan merriman on the first big
movie that i did
um i
i wasn't even in the scene and there was
a scene where he got drunk and he goes
over to
a woman's house and and he
tries to woo her but he's drunk
and the way that he played it
was so perfect because he was playing
sober
and i i was captivated we were on a
sound stage and they had a three wall
set belt and it was late at night and
i'm watching him and i was like i've
seen you drunk like i know what you look
like drunk
and you're not playing drunk he's like
no i'm playing sober
and then
because and then
there there would just be some small
things where it would be like and you
would see the crack in the veneer and
the slip that's what makes you lean
forward in every performance
um the problem is and this is the true
skill and this is what i still do seek
and chase after is when that's no longer
a conscious choice
but when it is something that is just
inherent
my my best moments and typically the
ones where people go that was that was a
great performance or when i could
literally when they say cut it's like
that was great like i have no idea what
just happened and i thought it was this
out of body experience i just couldn't
tell you like can you do a favor and do
the exact things like couldn't tell you
where i was all i knew i would i could
tell you what she was doing i could tell
you what he was doing no idea what i was
doing hmm
um
but like you look at to to speak to your
example austin marlon brando my favorite
performance of marlon brando
is
probably guys and dolls like the one
that i enjoy him in the most and he's
just
reserved
not on the waterfront not streetcar
named desire not even godfather i love
the godfather but i love ev
robert duvall to me is what that movie
is just all about tom hagan is just the
most tragic beautiful character
um and it's before robert duvall got big
it's like we watched the etymology in
the in the beginnings the genesees of
these characters these character actors
and robert duvall is known to shout al
pacino is known to shout marlon brando's
known to shout and it's their quietest
moments even um what's his name uh
james khan
he doesn't he does a couple of shouting
things but for the most part he's just
holding it all in and that to me is
what's terrifying it makes me remember
how
um
uh chris farley
um who was you know such an over-the-top
comedian just such like incredible
physical commitment to everything
uh
i think probably my single favorite bit
ever of his was the saturday night live
skit called the chris farley show yeah
where he's really quiet and shy and
nervous and he's talking about
everything and yeah and he's like hey
hey paul remember remember the beatles
they said yeah yeah of course i do
that was awesome
and he's just he's so
god he's just so good in that scene
uncomfortable but do you do you enjoy
that for the negative space do you enjoy
that more because you have the image in
your head of what he normally is right
that whole joke requires the knowledge
of it for the roles yeah
he's playing with the negative space
there he's kind of doing something that
relies on what you're not seeing yeah
it's like it's like there's stored
potential energy that you're aware of uh
yeah i i think that's an interesting
question i i think that surely part of
it i think it's also i think it's one of
those if you've never seen it
it would be funny
and if it's funnier if you know how
against type he's being
you know so it kind of exists on two
levels i i i would suspect
he did yeah but he also just naturally
did awkward well it's it's that you know
the
where you take a an unnecessary boss
dude oh he's slightly short of breath
yeah
speaking of performances yeah
how about that
we're gonna get into it we said we would
it's true here we are shouldn't we wait
until the last 15 minutes of the show i
know
we could have i also wanted to apologize
the spoiler warning that i gave last
week was a second before i said the
spoiler and a lot of people rightfully
called me out for that i think in my
head i was like well this isn't the
actual spoiler this is just like the
thing that you find out early but it was
still shitty of me i apologize on behalf
of the play watch listen crew for my
very bad spoiler warning you're right to
call me outstanding minus ten points
[Laughter]
there goes gryffindor
mike and okay so now let me give another
spoiler warning we will probably spoil
12 minutes yeah so if buy if you don't
want anything about it buy i'm not going
to do it a second later mike you had
something that you wanted to
bring up right comparative what was it
well i know what it was because it was i
i basically my hypothesis was awesome
the game
the game could have benefited from a
zillion more
variations and things like that on
lines of dialogue even if it was the
same line because there's certain
there's a lot of different tracks into
specific
uh moments of in the sort of
conversation
um
and it always funnels to the same line
the same delivery and my hypothesis was
a lot of the budget was eaten up by your
expensive talent and if it had been
cheaper talent they may have been able
to record like a lot more content to
just get over the fact that you had this
it was forcing the actors to sound
wooden because they were obviously not
reacting to the line that just happened
the lines were in a vacuum unto
themselves they were never bad reads
like these are all good actors but they
just are
it's like if i said to you
you know
mike your family's all been murdered and
and then you're like
that's strange it's like it's just like
let's have that dessert now
yeah it felt like you can say that's
strange the most convincing possible but
that's not how you would say that
in that context in any righteous way so
it was to me it felt i got a lot of
thoughts on it but but you're apparently
your your specific pushback was like
it's
so i didn't actually push back on that
because i think what you're saying is
genuinely true like you've if you've got
like a you know x budget for voice over
then theoretically yes you could get
more time out of a cheaper actor for
sure and 100 percent we do those sums
right behind the scenes like definitely
like you've got a budget in mind and you
want because i would think a per session
rate on some level it just eventually
comes down to the kind of granular how
fast can we move and what is our burn
rate through
time and like different actors are
different and different levels of
experience of actors are different like
yeah no for sure no i think what i think
what happened what i remember
remembering what i dm'd about was here's
some information
oh there's siri jumping here's some
information wait a minute
i do have so i this is where i reveal i
have australian siri because i like the
voice more than the english
um
stay on target i'm trying to think where
i was oh yeah so your your point i
think's there i think yeah for sure i
think what was what i specifically was
like oh that's interesting and that's a
that's a misunderstanding i see among
kind of gamers quite a lot was i think
someone in the comments on the last
episode said something along the lines
of
oh surely if they'd spent less on voice
acting then they could have done you
know more design work they could have
spent that money on development in a
different way i think that was the thing
that i saw in the comments yeah what you
said was someone in the comments said if
they hired lesser actors couldn't they
do more design iteration
yes and i see that a lot because i think
the audience
definitely looks at like you know money
spent and goes well if they're not
spending money here then they could
spend money there
and it's way more complicated than that
in a really interesting way so that was
the thing i always talk about so you're
saying that's not invariably true
no how is that not true it's almost
invariably false so but i would think
it's only armed me with information when
i'm negotiating my next statement
this is very dangerous information if
i'm never going to cast troy anything
ever again
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
on like a literal level yes there's a
pot of money that's gonna be spent on a
game and money going out to a voice
actor cannot be spent elsewhere and if
you get a cheaper voice actor there's
more money
yes however the impact of a specific
actor is is is not the same as people
would expect for a couple of reasons
the first one which is kind of specific
to kind of publisher platformy things
is it's possible the voice actor isn't
being paid out of the development budget
um that's possible in a lot of cases
voice actors are paid for by marketing
right because often right a big name
into a game is a marketing decision like
you you go well you know we we think we
could cast this with you know great
voice actors but not famous voice actors
and you know a
publisher or a platform holder might be
like well we kind of want this to feel
you know worthy or like it's important
and we'll actually spend some money on
voice actors
and i've definitely been aware of times
in the games industry where the
developers turned around and gone cool
well that's marketing then so you're not
spending any of our money on that right
and that's and that's actually worked as
a negotiation in terms of
ostensibly would you not say that that
money still is going to get attributed
back to the developer in some way no
because because development budgets and
this is the other aspect of it
development budgets are worked out ahead
of time so it's not the case it won't
come out of your development budget but
it will still come back to the developer
right
publisher is going to go we spent this
much money by the way you're on the tab
for that we're going to we're going to
take this out of your
partially but it might be that they
actually take that marketing money that
they're spending on the actor and take
that out of something they're going to
spend elsewhere they go well you know we
want big name actor we'll just do two
days at e3 instead of three that's that
kind of sum that they might be doing
themselves so there's that kind of thing
where it's not necessarily like a direct
trade-off that's actually that's a minor
thing but it's it's definitely a factor
the biggest one
is i think people consistently
assume that voice acting costs a lot
more than it does in the audience
compared to other disciplines that
contribute to a video game that's
definitely true i would think yeah no i
think i think people get it i think
people see like movie actors and they're
like okay so you know i don't know movie
actor x is paid 10 million for a big
hollywood movie right and i think what
the average kind of player maybe kind of
comes away from that with is that's how
much it costs to get an actor to get out
of bed and go to a studio for a day to
record something and that's not true
that's how much it costs to have like
four months of that person on set
three months of them doing the world
tour of interviews for the
owning their appearance for a full six
months they can't change anything and
for future merchandise and all of this
stuff and and then you know the netflix
sale and all of it like there's just a
lot of stuff that that money's paying
for you're basically buying almost a
year of someone's life in a lot of those
kind of blockbuster contexts with a
voiceover you're paying for someone's
afternoon so even if you were just to
take kind of
10 million and divide it into you know
the days and then like
work out what half a day is worth even
then like that's not necessarily a
number because voice actors will
absolutely especially uh movie stars
will often not worry about their rates
if they think a script's cool or if
there's an opportunity to work with
someone they want to work with or if
it's a kind of a strange interesting
thing
voice a voice actor even like a famous
movie star voice actor that everyone in
this audience would have heard of
doesn't cost me the developer much more
than like
a couple of months of one designer's
time it's not like it's not a ridiculous
kind of uh discrepancy i think we think
of voice actors as costing like hundreds
of thousands or millions of dollars and
it's it's simply not the case on
the kind of scale of production the 12
minutes that 12 minutes was that yeah
yeah i think that's a very important
distinction because you start getting
into a triple-a time oh if they're
getting you in a mocap suit for three
months troy that's a very different
situation it's a different conversation
but like a perfect example is having a
conversation with someone about pedro
pascal
and the the particulars are not
important but how annoyed at him you are
for him being in the in the show is that
right you're like you're like
he's he's a he's a good friend and he
was expressing frustration that he was
like i can't believe he's like why
didn't you get paid what he's gonna get
paid
he's like you're deserving of that and
i'm like i don't ever want to get into
what i deserve ever because the second
we get into deserving this is not me you
know virtue signaling it's like what i
deserve is not anywhere near
what i'm getting i'm it is a people are
very gracious
and i work my ass off for it but if i
mean to get what i deserve i don't want
to get i don't want anything to ever be
a metric of that so let it be something
that is external and is is qualified by
other things besides my virtue or
whatever so
also worth qualifying that that him
getting cast in the show
at this point in his career is very
different than where you were in your
career when you were casting absolutely
i was like people might have heard my
name in a small subset of a very you
know at that point a smaller section of
the entertainment industry
homie's coming off of mandalorian he's
coming off of so much stuff he's pedro
pascal and i even told my friends like
because you're troy baker i was like
yeah but he has to be pedro pascal
like i get to just be me there's a
there's a lot of things a lot of
freedoms that come with that like you
said alana they're buying his appearance
for he's like you need to look like this
not for just the next year let's talk
about walking dead
norman reedus is like
this hair is driving me crazy you know
i'm i'm ready to there are so many
people that are like i'm just ready to
look different
because you need to you need to be this
for a long time
uh kari paid the same thing he's like
kari payton always had he can't remember
he came into a session one time and i
was like you shaved your head he was
like
yeah about that
and i was like what's going on and
that's when i found out that he was
going to be on walking dead because he
had this
amazing afro i loved his hair
so there's a lot of things that happen
when someone gets involved in a
production of that size
but there's also
different money that is attributed to it
when you buy a game you buy it once it's
different for a movie or a show because
hbo is going to do the last of us right
i have no idea
what that looks like around the world
because it could be sky in the uk it
could be something that's completely
different it could be on netflix
in spain so it's just a completely
different thing so there are that that
show is going to be a commodity that is
as like every other show is bought and
sold by different people
and commercials will be run on it
perhaps in other parts of the world so
there's different forms of revenue that
are being come in so they can afford to
do something of that budget
or or of that you know payday for him
but there's just a lot of other things
that go into it any actor that comes in
going i demand royalties and i demand
the same thing that you would pay an
actor on that it's like there's no
metric for that dude that's not how it
works
so i i feel
i feel like i got a good grasp on it but
the the thing that you pointed that is
very true is it the the association
between 18 months 24 months or even just
six months on a film
versus
you came in for two four hour sessions
if i have a mocap day even if i have a
mocap day my the my longest part of that
day is going to be 10 hours maybe
most of them are gonna be eight so it's
it's a sweet gig i love performance
capture it really really is great
there's a lot of things that i give up i
give up being on a cool set with set
design and wardrobes and props that are
practical
i've you know it's
i can't even get into it but there is a
difference i loved working on that
western and being up on a horse and
riding through a town that they built
that looked as if it was a town in 1863
i loved that i don't get that on a on a
stage
so let me let me
ask um
just
kind of
i'm doing this now twice i'm kind of
i'm kind of like
you know lassoing
five minutes ago uh
and you have a last name because you're
on a live-action set it's not just like
yeah a string with uh yeah
um
the
the thing that's
with regard to 12 minutes what's so
fascinating to me is that obviously
there's no
attempt at anything resembling likeness
with the characters
and so one thing i genuinely don't
understand
is why these actors why mcavoy and daisy
ridley were directed into
accents so wildly different from their
own natural
when
because that means you if you don't know
it's them you wouldn't know it's them
now on the one hand that's pretty
impressive as an acting feat but why
would you cast someone to deliberately
obscure them except for the poster which
the part two of that question is
is there anyone on planet earth that
bought that game because of their names
uh i think i think a lot of the coverage
and kind of reputation of that game is
is tied to
a lot of people would have been like
oh that's even if they didn't buy it
because of that they remember that maybe
like it becomes a real game right we've
had this before like when we cast like
andy circus as the villain in volume
like we just got so much more press just
because it's like oh oh this is
it's legitimacy like it matters yeah it
really does at the indie scale
especially i think i think there's an
argument austin that it does less at the
aaa end like if you cast like a big
movie star in like your your triple a
shooter people say negatively in some
cases actually yeah can i ask either of
you michael troy i have no idea if this
is even answerable
if you could guess and specifically not
austin i'm not interested in your take
yes
audio listeners he turned this webcam
off um could you mute as well please
austin for us
yeah
how long do you think
not you austin how long do you think
they're recorded for is there any way
that you can guess that based on the
lines of dialogue that are in there like
i feel like not long i don't feel like
these were super long sessions and i
don't feel like there are that many
lines my guess is
i've definitely got an idea in my head
two sessions with probably a three or
four session guarantee would be my guess
and to speak to your point i also like
about last
ah i don't know just just to round up
the
just because the way the deal is
structured they would have had to have
said we're going to give you x amount of
dollars but we have to attribute that
somehow so we're saying that you are
based on this amount of money we're
giving you
that broken out over four sessions would
be this because if for some reason they
needed to come back and do another
session that agent's gonna go all right
but you know you realize that that's
going to be an additional x because that
amount of money broken up over four
sessions equal x per session
so this is how we structure our deals
all the time to where and and i've i've
there's not a lot of people that are
doing what you're talking about mike so
i i love that you bring that to the
forefront my agent is amazing and
there's been a lot of times where she's
like
for the record troy's agent is fonky
jansen from goldeneye
it's so austin always believes with it
latonya she's incredible
um but the tanya was the weirder it's
accurate yeah
she natalia is the first person that i
would ever like when the people came out
and they said this is how much money we
have for this she's like totally
understand that
let's get creative are we able to pull
from marketing and
attribute some of that money to be able
to say that troy will
do a tour we'll we'll um do some
marketing assets for you as well he
loves to be an ambassador for the game
he loves to talk about this is there
anything we can do and they're like oh
my gosh yes and so
she was able to either get me more money
or get me up to it may have been a
smaller project where they're like we
don't have that much money she's like
totally understand do you maybe have
that in a marketing budget and they were
like yes we can do that so getting
creative about your deals as opposed to
demanding a higher rate a lot of times
if you're by the way if you're actors
listening to this
don't depend upon a standard
to to tell you how to do your business
because that standard was a one-off at
one time
it became a standard because people kept
doing it so
if you want something
ask for it it's the first
great piece of advice i got on my very
first job lou diamond phillips he goes
if you believe in something and you
believe that it's right ask for it from
the onset don't wait until you quote
become something or achieve some level
he goes that's arrogance and ego if it's
right it's right for you right now but
just make sure that it's the right thing
you're not just being selfish so if you
want to structure a deal in that way say
can we do this but to ask for a higher
rate
most producers or directors look at that
and go
dude i i think that i've got this i'm in
a situation right now where we're
dealing with that they're like we have
to make sure that we're not
offering a session rate that's too high
because they could come back and bite us
in the ass later if we had to do more
sessions and we'll actually go over
budget so it could be like can we do
something different uh structure that
deal but my guess sorry throwing it back
to you mike my guess would be that they
did two sessions and they probably did
like a three or four session guarantee
i would love to be wrong
that's totally that's totally reasonable
that may well be it i think
if i'm obviously it's all fanfic right
because none of us know the deal if this
was a bethel game i'm guessing we could
bring in willem troy baker stop yelling
stop yelling for one stop willem willem
willem willem willow call me back when
you call me i'm like colin williams 19
20's journalist
it'll be fine get me daisy ridley please
stop yelling i think
i think at the indie scale i think
especially with a cost which is two
brits
so you're probably recording it in the
uk which where the expectations are a
little lower i i think you could do this
i think this is a four-hour session with
both daisy ridley and james mcavoy each
i think they're doing four i i think i i
think just thinking about like how much
dialogue we've recorded in the past or
with with actors like this
uh
the only issue would be that i don't
think either of them have done lots of
voiceover i think james mcavoy has done
a few animated movies so he's got a bit
under his belt i don't know if daisy
ridley is so that would be that would be
kind of unknown but i think i think i
think given the amount of dialogue
that's recorded there and the simplicity
of the situation and to be honest to
austin's point the lack of kind of
responsiveness and variability in the
lines given i think probably you're
looking per act or about 200 lines maybe
three
and i think you could rush down indie
budget in a four-hour session willem
dafoe
there's more of so i think possibly for
him i'm probably landing in the same
place as you i think it's probably about
two sessions and maybe they did some
negotiation to cover extra stuff it
doesn't feel like a voice over
and i say this this isn't meant to be
disrespectful it doesn't feel like they
did retakes of these lines these feel
like it feels like one session recording
to me i feel like they were um
[Music]
very intimidated to direct and i've been
in situations like that before where
i've been with the celeb and they're
like
troy can you just uh
change everything that you're doing uh
so and so you're fantastic and they're
like what the [ __ ] i want to be directed
to i'm still an actor
um i'm trying to look up and see if
daisy i i as i understand um
willem dafoe moves he's a he's a has got
a great work ethic and he moves with a
bit of alacrity and and and skillful
adeptness in that situation specifically
is my favorite he might be able if he's
a great voice actor he might be able to
do four-hour session to get all of this
like genuinely there's not many lines
like i think you're looking at about 200
you can get the 204 hours which yeah you
could do that in four hours for sure
that would be if your experience i
wouldn't do that with like a novice or
an actor who i was casting like as a
stunt casting i knew hadn't done much
voice over but like looking back at like
our stuff like i generally people i get
asked a lot because our games have a lot
of voiceover in them because we've
worked with some some of the bigger
names i do get other indies ask me a lot
like what's the possible thing and i my
usual stock answer is 200 lines about
four hours if they know what they're
doing um and exactly what you said troy
of like there might be actors who want
to take a bit more time work a little
harder on it want to do a longer deal
and and that can be where that comes in
but in terms of like a bare minimum 200
lines in four hours is is very
achievable with a good director as well
that's the other aspect of that barry
pepper was an interesting person because
barry loves to come in in the booth he's
like moving around and he will just like
the line could be doesn't matter it
could be a very short or very long line
and he just goes and he just you have to
basically go stop you're good we got it
move on he was like because he'll just
give you 50 takes of the line
and he comes out for just profusely
sweating then there's people like dan
aykroyd who on ghostbusters
did most of his sessions took one
15-minute break into four hours and just
cranked
so there's just different people have
different work ethics looping
which you know adr that that most people
who have done a movie or a show or
will have done some form of looping uh
or some ver uh um some volume of looping
um
that moves at such an incredibly
painstakingly slow pace yeah that when
people come in and lots of repetition as
well like just doing the same i thought
it was over and over and over no you
have to match picture they have to load
even just the sure fact of the engineer
moving to the clip and lining it up and
moving and adding it in watching it
describing um putting yourself back in
that's that state and telling why are we
doing because a lot of times like wait a
minute i love what i did it's like if
it's not for an airplane why are we
redoing this slides like well or we're
adding this line in and well that's too
long of a of a line because they're
adding us thinking off-camera
learning about adr was one of the most
eye-opening things when i first got
started in this business and realizing
like so many times if you disconnect
from an actor's performance it's
probably because they had to record that
line in a [ __ ] booth six months after
they shot it yeah totally disconnected i
ten ish years ago
i did a film that had jenna fisher from
the office and the they invited me to
her adr session and i was sitting in the
booth and she was
mind-blowingly good at it and it was one
of those i turned to the engineer and i
was like because i hadn't i think i i
think i'd ever been to one of those
before
and i said is this normal because she's
never out of sync with herself and he
was like she's inordinately good at this
because so many times you do three takes
two of them don't work because you're
just a little bit off and it's
noticeable um and she was just like you
know you hear the
bump and then she does it and it was
like it's [ __ ] perfect i i just
remember thinking
holy [ __ ] this is and this is like a
little indie drama like
you know these big giant
blockbuster things where you know
they're running around on a set and it's
all being added with special effects and
what like none of those lines are usable
none of that it's you're recreating the
entire movie in the booth watch hugh
jackman um
loop his own efforts
for i think it was wolverine
it may have been the wolverine movie uh
i don't think it was one of the x-men
movie and he is watching it and he's
doing oh dude
i was like
bro that is that is some veteran [ __ ]
right there he crushes it um he is just
so he's such a good excellent every
every every there's not one
film of his or one performance of his
where i'm not just
entranced even guys even though he went
back in time that was that was still
charming um like this is the style of
spoilers for 12 minutes
that bit where it turns out they're
aliens like didn't work but the rest of
it was
but i genuinely think like if if best
cameo by jesus christ
best cameo hands down if if those three
actors are as good as we as as the
examples we're using and as i suspect
probably they are yeah i think you could
do this in a day and a half total yeah
like recordings see that to me that
is the flaw of this game i must say i'm
gonna change my answer because i i feel
like that dance number probably ended
entirely differently yeah that would be
tough yeah
i mean there is a dance so that's true
there it is
spoilers i really i really uh i really
i know we're out of time but i i just
think that that game
needed like 10 times more dialogue to
work um so that there's more variation
uh because it really felt like
it felt like
you designed a puzzle where the key is i
have to go pick this object up and put
it down over there except that the
object
and this location in that location are
all lines of dialogue so it's like
they're conceived of abstractly and then
and then lines
put in there
right it's like a point-and-click
adventure where the pointing and
clicking is largely dialogue there are a
couple of required items but it is
mostly a dialogue and it's like
connecting circuits
there's a reason we didn't put voice
over in subsurface circular and it's
this is like you can get away with so
much with text on a page
on here before but like implication like
we deliberately wrote there's like 50 of
the dialogue in sub-surface circular is
deliberately written to read correctly
depending on like different contexts
like oh you know a character comes up to
you and says oh you you were so helpful
earlier and you're meant as a player to
be able to either read that as like an
earnest description of something you did
or a sarcastic joke about something you
did and either way you feel like the
game was paying attention to you and
we've achieved our goal but if we were
to do that with voice over which has
come up a lot when we've talked to
different people about doing more with
those ideas
it always comes down to well we would
have to re-record every line of dialogue
five times to make this work and that's
probably not worthwhile for
the experience the player is going to
have in there right
it's really and also crucially as well
when you're making dialogue um
into gameplay the other thing is
dialogue's not responsive in terms of
like timing as well like if you it's
amazing what they've achieved like with
say mass effect where you actually enjoy
the dialogue that i think people
underestimate how hard it is to design
dialogue to be entertaining from a game
design point of view because you're just
listening to something for 10 minutes
based on a decision you made so it's
kind of there's a lot of i'm not sure i
think you're right austin but i think
the problems leading to the problem i
think you've got the i think you've
you've diagnosed the problem but i think
the illness is like five steps back
you've found the symptoms but not the
cause the symptom but not the illness
yeah
can i ask just for the purposes of
trying to inform um since we've spoken
around this so much in this conversation
and i know this is a difficult question
answer but what is the cost of voice
acting we've not actually given any kind
of number well i can tell you troy's
cost um
it's it's so varied like i i think that
right now because the problem is you
can't what are you attributing that to
are you attributing that to the actors
payments because like i can tell you
right now the actor payment i think the
scale is like
it's for sag for yeah the sag
screen actors guild sag minimum payment
for a for a interactive title
four hour session
is like 10 19
so 1 000 19 cents to the actor
now and that's but that's only if you're
going to america and you're going union
exactly if you go non-union lower than
that wild wild west you can get away
with a whole bunch of but you're still
going to fall somewhere within that
parameter because you go too low people
like hey but these people are getting
this
where that really makes a difference to
producers is that's what the actor gets
but there's also a plus 10 on top of
that for the agent then there's also you
have to pay into their pension and
health and welfare that's gonna
well yeah but that's that's included in
that the
the taxes if like i'm a corp so
they don't take any taxes out i take
care of my own taxes but the taxes that
that wouldn't be on top of that it would
be the pension health and it basically
it brings it up to like i think sixteen
hundred dollars every four hour session
every actor
scale base minimum payment that they
have to pay
so
that gets crazy those fringe benefits
are 60 percent on top it's something
once once you get into
unionized
sorry but it makes it it makes it um
we run into this one
the musicians union has the exact same
thing and this is why no one hires them
because it makes it completely
unaffordable prohibitively expensive
yeah and they don't have the bargaining
chip
that the screen actors guild has of like
well look we want tom cruise
there's just no way around it like
it must be a signatory production which
then trickles to all the other actors
like the musicians union
has zero bargaining chip for that and so
they just basically priced themselves
into oblivion it's it's sad because
they're such talented musicians but the
fringe benefits add so much to the cost
i don't know a solution to that short of
a total rethinking of how the union
operates
yeah but it's it's also the
understanding that there's still a lot
of studios in mike i don't talk out of
turn but i i know this there's a lot of
studios that operate as we have an audio
budget
and that's where
actors get paid composers
will force that on you yeah so it's like
this is this is our toilet paper this is
our dev you know your coding cost this
is our this is how much we have to pay
for rigs but like you start getting into
most people don't know this but you
start getting into a performance capture
day
single day and on on average it's going
to be between 50 and 65 000 a day
to step onto that mocap stage with like
four apples
and that is why on the last episode i
said i suspect the animation costs more
than the acting
because when you think about how much
mocap is in this game yeah that was
another thing that would not have been
willem dafoe on stage but it would have
still required all of the infrastructure
and the engineers and the the team the
producers of motion capture performance
is beyond why do you think they did that
why do you think they mocapped this game
it seems a very unlikely game for that i
didn't understand i want to reach out to
advisor rouge and go what was it what
was going on what's going on there yeah
like it's i don't i say that judgment
free i just didn't understand what it
offered that sort of traditionally just
animating those characters
mocaps great for bespoke which i think
would probably be the argument here
would be that if so so if you want to
make a run cycle you shouldn't mocap
here you should you should probably hand
key animate 100
but if you need blending shapes
yeah you need stuff like that though you
can still use stock animation but if you
need to blend between like hey what is
what does
x character's idle look like before he
goes back into our
you know
yeah we've said mo caps great if you
need an hour of things that are unique
and this game does have that in terms of
like the animations of characters moving
through the space
it's it's it's there is a little bit of
jank in there in the joins between the
animation but there are a lot of very
specific animations so i can understand
the argument for it um animation's a
tricky one and to be honest i'm not
gonna i've definitely messed up
animation on previous projects so i'm
not gonna definitely not gonna claim any
kind of uh genius on this but like it is
it is tricky and mocap yeah mocap's
expensive i suspect the methodology they
used was cheaper i suspect this probably
wasn't using the full-on mocap situation
this was probably you know your classic
kind of six degree of motion kind of uh
straps what's that called troy the
well i mean the inside out kind of
tracking yeah yeah so they probably just
had a limited marker set so that they
were not doing like the full fidelity
they had two rigs they had two you know
one male one female
um but that that alone is probably going
to cost 10 grand a rig so that's 20 000
automatically just right there that's a
one-time cost and then you have
all of the cleanup so like when you go
to a mocap shoot and you shoot that
all the computer sees is like a vectrex
version of your body with all these
different little markers on it and then
this is me doing some mocap data before
cleaning
i appreciate that and it could also be
where my paranormal activity [ __ ] right
there it looks like you're an
interpretive dance to what troy's saying
where my shoulder is may not be where
the character model's shoulder is so
then they have to quote solve that
and that is a whole batch process that
they have to do
so depending upon the studio they could
have a great front end which means their
their
character models and their rigs are
great their animation is great but then
they don't have that back end to be able
to process that or so they have to
outsource that to another team or
they've got okay on the front end they
need some help with all of that design
and then all of the back end they're
great at processing that within their
engine so that varies a cost so people
like how much does it cost to show a
mocap stage i'm like what's your studio
what's your game what's your rig what
are you needing how many actors do you
have on shadow of war we had on one day
we had eight
actors
on the stage at a time we almost broke
the system because we have you start
getting eight wireless transmissions of
of
64 dots on each so whatever the factor
of 8 to 64 is it's for days like about 5
000 points they're just moving around in
space is crazy or 500 points sorry just
to add something to troy what troy said
earlier the um
with the baseline kind of pay with zag
afro it's true what he's saying that's
obviously that is the number but there's
also
if you're if you're outside of america
so if you're in the uk let's say you're
a prestige cast two of them are british
and probably in britain um then those
numbers change because sagafra doesn't
have jurisdiction essentially over here
so you british actors will it can it can
vary some actors who work a lot in
america will still want to work under
sag afro and you've got to work navigate
that that stuff but yeah basically
british british vo i would say usually
kind of trends lower in price the other
thing is the upper end
of the scale value that's we're talking
like a hundred times what the number
troy said for like if you want tom
cruise to come in for four hours like
that's that's uh
god knows what that number would even be
um so yeah so it can go there's no upper
limit there's no cap on that and it also
of course as with everything troy said
earlier
there's a lot of negotiation there
beyond just how good an actor is this
person and or even how famous they are
if you're an actor who's in game two in
a franchise you have a very different
negotiation position than you had for
the first game if you're an actor who
has just had a hit
uh you know a big tv show or movies just
happened then your value's going to go
up um i've literally had it and i won't
say the name but an actor who we'd cast
in something
who got a job no unfortunately not truly
uh because you've got you're you're more
reliable than this guy this guy when and
he got a job in like a big tv show and
just walked off the project because a he
had to go and make this tv show fair
enough b
his stock value just
doubled overnight because of that frank
because he was in a big tv show which he
wasn't in when we started so there's a
lot of that kind of stuff as well so
it's a it's a tricky one the big advice
to indies if you're listening this and
think about it get yourself a voice
director even if you think you can do it
it's one of my biggest regrets is like i
never did that at the start and i kind
of had to learn this all secondhand and
kind of still kind of struggle with
voice direction a little bit
two it's okay to go and find a casting
director it's okay to find someone who's
going to help you find a voice and find
the kind of actors who would work on
your stuff and how that would work and
three like you know factor in the cost
of the recording you know you're gonna
have to get a studio the thing we left
out when we talked about how important
directors are and point actors are the
engineer those guys are gold like you
can find a good engine there that's
really such a massive difference as well
there's nothing more frustrating than
when you do a
an emotional scene or something that was
a very dynamic scene where
i do this all the time where it starts
off quiet gets really loud it goes by
quiet again
and you hear the engineer go oh sorry i
saw that that peaked
like
dude
you need to as a matter of fact uh when
we would be on a mocap stage if you look
you'll see these two little nodes like
little nodules right here those are two
microphones and they're dpa i can't
remember what the uh everybody uses now
dpf438s i think they're awesome mics but
they're like the little lapel mics that
go right here and they wire back the
reason why there's two is because
there's one set at a specific volume
essentially a gain stage and the second
one is significantly lower
so that if we have a temperature and it
gets really loud that happens all the
time in a game
don't worry we got on the backup and so
they're constantly tracking two versions
of the audio so that you don't have to
go in
that to have somebody be able to monitor
that buy the gear someone had to do a
cost ellis and go it's cheaper if we
just buy two mics yeah than to screw up
that amount of takes and have to come
back in an adr all of this [ __ ] that's
why
dude definitely speak in my language
right now yeah we did an adr
i mean i would say 70 to 80 of the stuff
that we got on the stage for the last
part two is in game
or um ended up being final 70 to 80
percent of the cinematics it's not
including all the video that we had to
do but um
or they had to do uh but there's there's
a lot of of stuff that we did for a lot
of games we're like we got it i'm like
damn dude um
miles morales most of the stuff that we
got we got on the stage it's great we
always do a safety take man we should do
like a whole i mean i'll do this like
like it'd be fun to do this with you as
well just to do like a little workshop
for everybody because there's a lot it's
it's a lot of information i would push
against by the way there's no real good
resources i'd love to see like uh just a
video that was like you know like a
director should do a how to make one
minute of voiceover hey look at that
like yeah we should do something like
that because that's just like there's no
resources the other thing to say as well
is all of the advice we've given is like
in a professional context there's also
it's amazing what people achieve just
with like
an off-the-shelf like wii remote to do a
mockup logan and darren on bastion yeah
dude yeah if you look at like
digital guys right like what they do
with the kind of the rigs they've got
set up like it's you can absolutely
don't be intimidated
in a low budget
play around in unity play around in
unreal it's there's you can go literally
to the store and buy stuff and it's it's
incredible the resources that you have
it is there's never been a better time
and never been an easier time
to to be an actor to be a game developer
to to be a writer you have more tools
at your disposal than ever before don't
let that be that in the comments in this
video there is probably like an actor
watching this who wants to work on an
indie game and indeed that's trying to
find an actor like you should definitely
try and find each other truly the
tagline of play watch listen create
stuff we support it and that brings this
episode to a close incredible tagline
was disagree with me ten percent
disagree with me baby but also create
stuff thank you for watching everybody
i'm alan pierce i'm a video game writer
that's mike bethel he's a video game
director that's rebecca he's a video
game actor and that's awesome he's a
video game composer we'll see you all
next week bye